[Aplausos]
[Música]
el secretario de estado rex tillerson el
jefe de la diplomacia de los eeuu acaba
de regresar de su primera gira por
américa latina'
[Música]
no ha sido el primer viaje oficial de un
alto cargo de la administración trump a
la región hace unos meses en el verano
de 2017 el mismísimo vicepresidente mike
pence tuvo su propia expedición
latinoamericana visitando panamá
colombia argentina y chile
creo que todos lo sabemos la relación
entre eeuu y latinoamérica es muy pero
que muy especial lo que no quiere decir
que sea buena y no lo digo sólo porque
en eeuu vivan cerca de 60 millones de
hispanos también por los precedentes
históricos los lazos comerciales y
muchas pero que muchas cuestiones de
seguridad
sin ir más lejos el 25 por ciento uno de
cada cuatro dólares del comercio de eeuu
tiene como destino esta región sin
embargo amigos lo cierto es que la
sensación que han dejado las giras del
vicepresidente y el secretario de estado
es que a ojos de esta administración a
ojos de la administración trump
latinoamérica es más una molestia que
una oportunidad
y ojo porque decir esto con todo lo que
ha dicho trump desde que anunció que se
presentaría a las elecciones creo que es
quedarse muy pero que muy corto en
máximos se han suscripto de nats ending
deudas no monas monas el hambre del wind
twitter play to world we have no jobs we
are noche mirad si tuviéramos que
describir la relación entre estados
unidos y latinoamérica hoy podríamos
decir que eeuu es como ese amigo que te
está todo el día pidiendo y exigiendo
cosas pero que a la hora de la verdad no
está dispuesto a hacer absolutamente
nada por ti si podríamos decir que eeuu
se está convirtiendo en ese amigo
egocéntrico una buena prueba de ello fue
la surrealista gira de mike pence una
gira así en prácticamente objetivos en
la que el vicepresidente estaba más
preocupado en tratar de impedir las
insignificantes relaciones comerciales
entre chile y corea del norte
de conseguir que los argentinos
compraran la carne de cerdo de su estado
de indiana que de las mismísimas
relaciones entre eeuu y latinoamérica de
locos
[Música]
está bien
de color
[Música]
pero sabéis que la china de xi jinping
está al acecho pues bien en este vídeo
vamos a ver qué quiere que espera donald
trump de américa latina y también qué
ocurre con china pero antes veamos un
poquito de historia
[Música]
américa para los norteamericanos
en 1823 el por aquel entonces presidente
de eeuu james monroe puso en marcha la
que más tarde se conocería como la
doctrina monroe américa para los
americanos aunque con el paso del tiempo
casi que ha quedado más como américa
para los norteamericanos veréis esta
doctrina
esta política consistió en defender que
los estados europeos no tenían derecho a
intervenir en los asuntos americanos ni
en los países que por aquel entonces se
estaban independizando de españa' un
momento eeuu protegiendo a latinoamérica
defendiendo la no intervención suena
bien verdad pues esperado un momento
porque lo cierto es que esta doctrina
está política condujo a washington a
hacer prácticamente de todo en
latinoamérica una región que desde
entonces es conocida como el patio
trasero de eeuu
[Música]
tal cual como lo escucháis quienes nos
estáis viendo desde allí estoy seguro
que lo sabéis bastante bien desde que
james monroe puso en marcha esta forma
de ver las cosas
eeuu ha puesto gobiernos ha derribado
también gobiernos ha financiado
guerrillas ha financiado ejércitos ha
comprado políticos ha pactado con
narcotraficantes ha llegado a legitimar
golpes de estado y así una larga pero
que muy larga lista de acciones
dirigidas según la época viene a luchar
contra el comunismo viene a defender los
intereses de las grandes multinacionales
norteamericanas
[Música]
si ojo vamos a ver también se han hecho
cosas buenas sobre todo en los últimos
años cuando las relaciones más como
decirlo opacas dieron paso a una
estrategia por parte de washington más
enfocada a la resolución de conflictos
internos
este fue el caso por ejemplo del plan
colombia impulsado por bill clinton o de
la estrategia de impulso al comercio de
george bush que le llevó a firmar ni más
ni menos que 10 nuevos tratados de libre
comercio con países latinoamericanos e
incluso a proponer que toda américa se
convirtiese en una gran área de libre
comercio
pero aún así las relaciones entre
américa latina y eeuu siempre han sido
muy peculiares veréis en base a la
doctrina monroe
washington siempre se ha sentido una
especie de tutor legal capaz de decidir
que estaba bien y que estaba mal o que
era recomendable y que no era
recomendable pero otro tutor tiene que
tener claro que los intereses del
representado tienen que estar por encima
de los suyos propios y éste precisamente
no ha sido para nada el caso
[Música]
bien hace un año que donald trump está
en la casa blanca así que ahora sí
veamos qué quiere el presidente de eeuu
de latinoamérica que espera el que
podemos esperar nosotros veámoslo
qué quiere donald trump
creo que no es una sorpresa para nadie
donald trump no es el mayor fan de
latinoamérica su preocupación por la
región es muy pero que muy pequeña a
excepción eso sí de cuba venezuela y
sobre todo méxico
[Música]
y ojo porque trump muestra tan poco
interés por latinoamérica que un año
después de ser presidente aún no ha
nombrado a nadie para el cargo de
secretario de estado adjunto para
asuntos hemisféricos que viene a ser el
responsable específico de la diplomacia
con américa latina' algo absolutamente
insólito
eso sí una cosa bien clara que tenga
poco interés en las relaciones con la
región no ha impedido que la haya
convertido en el muñeco del pim pam pum
ni tampoco quiere decir que no espere
nada me explico el primer año de trump
ha estado marcado por los insultos a
méxico por su empeño con el muro ya he
llegado incluso a amenazar a colombia
como luego veremos
baby
wow
[Música]
hay dos tipos de which making the great
people
by mike pence y no sólo eso amigos
queréis algunos ejemplos más pues
atentos
durante 2017 trump también dio marcha
atrás lo vimos aquí en visual político
al acercamiento de obama con cuba sin
plantear eso si realmente ninguna
alternativa también recobrando las
peores costumbres de la diplomacia
norteamericana en américa latina' ha
legitimado y apoyado la sospechosa
reelección de juan orlando hernández en
honduras
y la última ya en 2018 su gobierno ha
decidido suspender el llamado estatus de
protección temporal para los inmigrantes
de nicaragua honduras haití y sobre todo
el salvador y ojo porque con esta
decisión 200.000 inmigrantes del
salvador 200000 tendrán que abandonar
eeuu o pasar a una situación de
ilegalidad teníamos la esperanza de que
si trabajábamos duro pagábamos impuestos
y no nos metíamos en problemas nos
permitirían quedarnos veronica lagunas
salvadoreña de 39 años y madre de dos
hijos nacidos en los eeuu e insisto
estos son sólo algunos ejemplos la lista
es larga
tal vez amigos esto es lo que explica
que el nivel de popularidad de trump en
la región sea tan tan bajo que digo bajo
está por los suelos en 2017
gallup preguntó a los ciudadanos de
américa latina' sobre qué opinión tenían
del presidente trump pues bien tan sólo
el 16 por ciento una de cada seis
personas dijo tener una opinión positiva
pero amigos hay una pregunta importante
que tenemos que hacernos tanto agravio
tanto meter el dedo en el ojo quiere
decir que traspasa de latinoamérica y no
busca no quiere nada de ella pues para
nada su gobierno está exigiendo varias
cosas a los países de la región pero
sobre todo tres principales
[Música]
primero un apoyo incondicional a su
política exterior incluida su política
con venezuela segundo que renuncien o
pongan freno a la influencia de china y
tercero que asuman las culpas de todo ya
sea pagando el muro o asumiendo más
responsabilidades en la lucha contra el
narcotráfico si salvo la cuestión de
china el resto de exigencias pueden
llegar a ser razonables pero sabéis cuál
es el verdadero problema
[Aplausos]
por eso me quedo
el verdadero problema es que la
administración de trump no pone sobre la
mesa alternativas no parece dispuesta a
dar nada a cambio y todo lo hace bajo el
planteamiento de estas conmigo o contra
mí pero vale puede que estéis pensando
vamos a ver a alberto seguro pero que es
que seguro que también ha puesto sobre
la mesa cosas positivas verdad pues creo
que para contestar a esta pregunta lo
mejor es ver como trump está tratando a
los mejores aliados de eeuu en la región
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los amigos
creo que podemos decir sin temor a
equivocarnos que colombia honduras y
méxico han sido tradicionalmente los
mejores aliados de eeuu en la región
pues sabéis que con trampa en la casa
blanca eso no está sirviendo de mucho
fijaos en estas declaraciones que trump
hizo mientras rex tillerson estaba de
gira tratando de fortalecer los lazos
con latinoamérica estos países no son
nuestros amigos saben pensamos que son
nuestros amigos y les mandamos ayudas
masivas y ahora no voy a citar sus
nombres les mandamos ayudas masivas y
están llenando nuestro país de drogas y
se están riendo de nosotros donald trump
si trump no da nombres pero no hay duda
de que se estaba refiriendo a mexico
colombia honduras y perú sobre méxico
que decir el muro la renegociación del
nafta el acuerdo de libre comercio los
ataques han sido continuos desde que
trump anunció su candidatura
no me extraña que los mexicanos le deis
a trump una valoración media de 16
puntos sobre 10 fijémonos también en
colombia el país que mejor relación ha
tenido históricamente con eeuu
[Música]
colombia fue el único país
latinoamericano que envió tropas a la
guerra de corea fue un país que le dio
su apoyo a eeuu en 2003 para la invasión
de irak y es un país cuyas políticas
siempre siempre han estado alineadas con
los intereses de washington ya fuese en
su política hacia cuba hacia china o
hacia palestina
pues ni siquiera eso ha impedido que
trump amenazas a este país con
considerarlo como no cooperante con el
cumplimiento de los compromisos
internacionales y la lucha contra el
narcotráfico algo que tendría serias
consecuencias económicas y políticas no
sólo es tratar de forma grosera un
aliado cercano que está intentando
resolver el problema es también un grave
error envía un mensaje tóxico al resto
de la región aún si hacen lo que pide
eeuu si están en desacuerdo con parte de
nuestra estrategia
reaccionaremos contra ustedes adam
isacson coordinador de la oficina de
washington para asuntos latinoamericanos
sí es verdad que la producción de coca
ha repuntado mucho en colombia y que el
país no ha sido capaz de vencer al
narcotráfico pero amenazar de esa forma
al país que más ha sufrido la guerra
contra los narcos sin proponer nada
diferente hemos perdido nuestros mejores
líderes nuestros mejores periodistas
nuestros mejores jueces nuestros mejores
policías en esta guerra contra el
narcotráfico juan manuel santos- y
respecto a honduras el otro gran aliado
y os voy a decir os hemos contado aquí
en visual político lo que ha ocurrido
con el más que probable golpe de estado
de juan orlando hernández e incluso en
argentina un país que está virando y que
no se sería lógico que washington le
echará un cable pues ni con esas trump
exige mucho a latinoamérica pero no está
dispuesto a dar nada a cambio ni
siquiera a los mejores amigos de eeuu en
esta región y china lo sabe
china al acecho
china la influencia china en la región
está empezando a ser una gran obsesión
para eeuu
el propio rex tillerson el secretario de
estado ha sacado a pasear la doctrina
monroe para decir que eeuu tiene el
derecho a bloquear la interferencia de
otra potencia en américa y me pregunto
yo quién le ha dado a eeuu ese derecho
américa latina no necesitan nuevas
potencias imperiales que sólo buscan
beneficiar a su propio pueblo rex
tillerson en la universidad de texas
tiene gracia que diga estas cosas
precisamente el secretario de estado de
los eeuu y sobre todo el secretario de
estado de una administración como la de
trump
[Música]
vamos a ver me explico los países
latinoamericanos tienen todo el derecho
del mundo a buscar alianzas mercados e
inversiones y si estas son chinas
tal vez lo que el señor tillerson
debería preguntarse es cómo es posible
que si jinping el presidente chino haya
visitado más veces la región en los
últimos cinco años que el presidente de
eeuu teniendo en cuenta tanto a barack
obama como a donald trump o que china
esté dispuesta a impulsar acuerdos
comerciales e inversiones mientras que
donald trump está empeñado en castigar a
méxico levantar muros o restringir el
comercio por ejemplo tumbando el pp el
mayor acuerdo comercial de la historia
en el que participaban entre otros
países méxico perú y chile
[Música]
fijaos en la última reunión de la
comunidad de estados de américa latina y
el caribe china anunció 250.000 millones
de dólares en inversión en la región
durante la próxima década si eeuu
quisiera mantener su peso su influencia
y seguir determinando la agenda política
tal vez debería tener una estrategia
política que realmente se preocupara de
los intereses de latinoamérica pero
ahora turno para ti del 1 al 5 cómo
valorarías la influencia de eeuu en
latinoamérica déjanos tu opinión en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
dale a like y por supuesto suscríbete
avisa al político si aún no lo has hecho
un saludo y hasta la próxima
en méxico se han suscrito de nats ending
de us no monas no buenas el hambre
el lector puede el producto
noche tras noche